Alright. The correct answer is that relational databases are
useful because it is straightforward to extract data with
complex queries. A database scales well. And relational databases
ensure data is consistently formatted. What do each of these
mean? Well, first off it's easy to extract data
from the database with a complex one line query. We
can easily say choose all records for people where
their age is greater than 50, and their weight is
less than 50, and the city is equal to Mumbai.
We can do this with flat files as well, but
its a lot more work. Database is also scale well.
Its not uncommon to have databases with hundreds of thousands
or millions of entries. Since all information is ideally stored
in one location, It's easy to update, delete, and add
new data to the database in a scalable way. Think
of the [UNKNOWN] data for example. India has a population
of 1.2 billion people. That's a really big data
set. It's important to have a solution that scales well.
Finally, relational databases have a concept of something called
a schema. Which basically says that each column in a
table Is always of the same type you can't
have some people's age be a string while the age
of others is an int. Relational databases are built
to have as little redundancy as possible that way if
we want to update a value we only have to do it in one place and we can ensure
that our data remains consistent throughout the entire database.
Also, relational databases are well established and have been used
for some time. Even if they were hot and
new, that's not a great reason to use a technology.
And now that we know why relational databases might be
useful, let's discuss how to use them in more detail.